die neue super rakete der nasa ist
bereit das space launch system sls ist
startklar
endlich wieder eine rakete vom format
der saturn 5 mondrakete eine super
wichtige hürde die die mondmissionen in
greifbarer nähe können die zeitpläne
eingehalten werden und inwieweit wird
ihren mast mit seinem unternehmen spacex
mitmischen klicks um science and future
bis dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
endlich auf der zielgraden die nasa ist
ein wichtiger meilenstein bei der
entwicklung des neuen space launch
system sls gelungen die hauptstufe und
die booster als wichtiger support für
den staat wurden jetzt das erste mal in
ihrer finalen konfiguration
zusammengesetzt das ganze nasa projekt
war bisher nur im minimalen
schneckentempo voran gekommen eine
enttäuschung folgte der nächsten
eigentlich sollte das sls bereits 2016
fertiggestellt werden zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt also im jahr 2021 sollten
eigentlich auch schon bemannte flüge
stattfinden
doch das alles wurde nichts unter
anderem die software entwicklung machte
der nasa einen strich durch die rechnung
doch jetzt ist eine wichtige hürde
genommen das space launch system wurde
erfolgreich aufgebaut die erste
unbemannte artemis teil mission soll im
november stattfindet emis ist der name
des neuen nasa mondprogramms bei diesem
testflug soll das sls eine orion
raumkapsel ins all bringen diese soll
dann zum mond und wieder zurück fliegen
fest steht die trägerrakete sls spielt
eine schlüsselrolle bei der geplanten
nasa mond-mission space launch system
sls ist 98 meter also etwa 20 stockwerke
hoch und achtung bis zu 28.000 400
kilometer pro stunde schnell
laut nasa die leistungsstärkste rakete
weltweit ende 2009 10 wurde die super
geht das erste mal offiziell von der
nasa präsentiert dazu sprach der
damalige nasa chef tim burtons zahlen
von zitat einen wichtigen meilenstein
und ein beweis für das amerikanische
unternehmertum und den erfindergeist
mehr als 1100 großen und kleinen
unternehmen in 44 staaten die zur
konstruktion und montage beitragen wird
die sls rakete amerika befähigen das
ziel des artemis programms zu erreichen
die erste frau und den nächst man bis
2024 auf dem mond zu landen
und das ist der große coup der nasa mehr
als 50 jahre nach der letzten
mondlandung soll dann also auch eine
frau teil der besatzung seien eine echte
premiere auch eine person of color soll
dabei sein und mit auf dem mond landen
inhaltlich möchte sich die nase am
südpol des mondes vor allem mit dem
wasser eis beschäftigen dass dort in der
vergangenheit aufgespürt werden konnte
im besten fall könnte es in sauerstoff
und wasserstoff aufgespalten werden doch
bei der entwicklung der super rakete gab
es immer wieder rückschläge und die
kosten schossen ins unermessliche erst
im märz diesen jahres dann ein kleiner
erster erfolg der komplette raketenstart
von acht minuten konnte simuliert werden
bei den vorherigen tests hatten sich die
rs 24 raketenantriebe vorzeitig
abgeschaltet der raketenantrieb des
space launch system sls war dann im
frühjahr diesen jahres im rahmen der
vorbereitungen für die artemis 1 mond
mission der nasa erneut getestet worden
und eben erfolgreich nachdem sich die
vier raketenantriebe beim vorherigen
test im januar vorzeitig abgeschaltet
hatten konnte nun der komplette
raketenstart von acht minuten simuliert
werden der test wird als hot feier
bezeichnet und alle vier triebwerke
feuerten für acht minuten und zehn
sekunden das entspricht dem start des
sls bis die rakete dann das weltall
erreicht erfolgreich getestet wurde
zudem auch die beweglichkeit der
einzelnen triebwerke laut nasa ist der
antrieb des sls das bislang größte
raketentriebwerk der nasa das aktuelle
video das die nasa jetzt präsentiert
zeigt wie die rakete im kennedy space
center konstruiert wird im zeitraffer
ist in den acht minuten zu sehen wie die
rakete mit den anderen teilen zusammen
gebracht wird insgesamt wird also so
eine höhe von 98 metern erreicht die
bilder der nasa zeigen jetzt die
hauptstufe die alleine 65 meter hoch ist
und rund 85.000 kilogramm wie die sms
pakete spielt eine schlüsselrolle bei
den mond missionen der nasa denn sie
trägt das gewicht der nutzlast der
oberen raketenstufe und der raumkapsel
darin werden sich dann die astronautin
astronaut befinden bei artemis 2 geht es
zunächst um die umrundung des mondes mit
artemis 3 ist dann tatsächlich die
mondlandung gemeint an der basisstufe
befinden sich außerdem die vier
triebwerke und zwei feststoffraketen
booster wie die nasa am metall in der
nächsten zeit stehen dann noch betankung
tests an sowie übungs countdowns klar
ist aber auch dass space launch system
ist eine entscheidung die rein politisch
motiviert es soll nach dem willen der us
politik möglichst viele arbeitsplätze
erhalten
doch dafür nimmt man seit langer zeit
viele nachteile in kauf sie ist sehr
teuer sehr komplex und ein riesiger
koloss dabei gebe es die möglichkeit us
astronautin astronauten auch anders auf
dem mond zu bringen
eine realistische option wäre zum
beispiel die zusammenarbeit mit dem
raumfahrtunternehmen von dem us space ex
technisch und finanziell gesehen wäre
das sogar ziemlich sinnvoll auch wenn
mit mass schwerlast rakete zwei starts
notwendig werden also mit der falcon
heavy um das notwendige equipment ins
all zu bringen
das ist auch einer der gründe warum sich
die meisten us politikerinnen und
politiker gegen spacex aussprechen denn
das space launch system wäre wenn es
dann mal fertig gestellt ist die
leistungsfähigste rakete der welt mit
nur einem staat könnte sie mond
raumschiff und lande modul ins weltall
bringen
auch die raumkapsel orion die
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner an der
spitze der sns rakete zum mond bringen
sollte
frisst jede menge geld ursprünglich war
sie als taxi zur iss zur internationalen
raumstation angedacht dann zum zu einem
asteroiden zu gelangen und dann für die
reise zum mond mittlerweile wiegt die
orion-kapsel zusammen mit dem service
modul 25 tonnen co dragon von space
extra gegen zehn tonnen eine falcon
heavy rakete könnte diese also zum mond
katapultieren für 200 millionen dollar
und nicht für zwei milliarden wie bei
der übergewichtigen sls kombi im april
hatte die nasa dann zumindest die
entscheidung getroffen dass basics die
landefähre bauen soll mit der die
astronautin astronauten auf dem mond
landen werden
26 hatte sich dabei gegen deine ticks
und gegen blue origin von amazon gründer
jeff bezos durchgesetzt konkret geht es
um das human landing system x es eine
mondlandefähre modell dass zwei
astronauten oder astronauten samt
ausrüstung zum mond
oberfläche bringen soll dort sollen sie
dann etwa eine woche bleiben
der vertrag zwischen space ex und nasa
beinhaltet einen umfang von 2,89
milliarden dollar
eine sehr ungewöhnliche entscheidung
dass nur ein einzelnes unternehmen einen
solch schweren auftrag bekommt in der
vergangenheit hatte die nasa immer
mehrere unternehmen ausgewählt so gab es
zahlreiche proteste und die
auftragsvergabe wird nun überprüft
zurück zum sls projekt ist staatlich
beauftragt und sein bau ist in vielen
us-bundesstaaten ein wichtiger
wirtschaftsfaktor
über die zahlreichen verzögerungen und
kostenexplosion wird deswegen
hinweggesehen
klar ist hier das geld fließt so oder so
die nasa gibt vor und das team von
boeing dass das space launch system
federführend betreut baut wünsche werden
hier nicht hinterfragt und der zeitdruck
ist hier gleich null
naja annähernd null wie steht es also um
die zeitpläne der nasa mond mission die
us regierung nimmt die geplanten abläufe
derzeit noch genauer ins visier die
chancen stehen gut dass artemis 1 noch
in diesem spätherbst also erfolgt
hierbei wird ein unbemanntes orion
raumschiff in die umlaufbahn unseres
erdtrabanten geschickt übrigens
angetrieben mit deutscher technologie
denn die sogenannten european service
models esm wurden hauptverantwortlich in
bremen gebaut von forschenden des
deutschen zentrums für luft und
raumfahrt und so wird esm 1 bremen
zurzeit am kennedy space center der nasa
in florida für seinen flug als teil des
orion raumschiff im spätherbst 2021
vorbereitet doch wie sieht es aus mit
der landung auf dem mond
wir hatten anfang des jahres bereits
exklusiv darüber berichtet und
zahlreiche quellen zusammengetragen sie
würzig ehemaliger interims chef der nasa
sagt jetzt das ziel der mondlandung 2024
könnte ein unrealistisches seien
angesichts der budget zuteilung der
letzten beiden jahre die nicht genügend
mittel bereit gestellt haben um 2024
erreichbar zu machen
vor diesem hintergrund überprüfen wir
das projekt hinsichtlich des
effizientesten weg ist wir werden also
warten müssen warum das erfahrt ihr in
diesem video exklusiv mondlandung für
2024 gestrichen
ziemlich spannende geschichte also
anklicken anschauen und vor allem
abonnieren diesen
danach ging's im science in future
einfach hier auf den abo button unter
dem video klicken ist kostenlos und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran